i
[Música]
llegó la hora de hablar de medio
ambiente en france24 mi nombre es maría
echara calle la autoridad ambiental
líder en todo el mundo galardonó a los
campeones de la tierra de 2021 este año
el programa de naciones unidas para el
medio ambiente le dio el premio a tres
mujeres y a un colectivo femenino que
combaten los mayores desafíos
ambientales del momento y hoy vamos a
destacar el trabajo que han hecho ellas
una de las galardonadas es la primera
ministra de barbados mía mottley por su
liderazgo político y es que es una de
las mandatarias que más ha exigido una
acción global
y cuanto más tenemos que hacer antes de
que el liderazgo estratégico y moral
llegue para world meets camps
cuanto más deben subir las temperaturas
globales para que terminemos con los
combustibles fósiles y cuanto más debe
subir el nivel del mar en los pequeños
estados insulares en vías de desarrollo
antes de que aquellos que sacaron
provecho de acumular gases efecto
invernadero
contribuyen a las pérdidas y daños que
ellos ocasionaron
en vez de pedirnos que desplazamos el
espacio físico que tenemos para el
desarrollo y dedicarlo curar el daño
causado por la avaricia de otros host
grados con discursos como este mía
mottley ha sido una de las lideresas que
más ha defendido a los países en
desarrollo que son los más vulnerables
al cambio climático especialmente a los
pequeños estados insulares que podrían
inundarse con el aumento del nivel del
mar como ocurre con su nación barbados
su apasionada defensa y sus logros
políticos son excelentes ejemplos de
como los líderes mundiales pueden tomar
medidas audaces y urgentes sobre
cuestiones ambientales
en su propio territorio la primera
ministra ha luchado contra la
contaminación el cambio climático y la
deforestación barbados tiene un
ambicioso plan para eliminar
gradualmente los combustibles fósiles
para 2030 la lidereza aspira a que casi
todos los hogares de la isla tengan
paneles solares y un vehículo eléctrico
además ella ha liderado la estrategia
nacional para plantar más de un millón
de árboles en la isla del este caribeño
que está cubierta en un 20% por bosques
su plan es fomentar la seguridad
alimentaria y desarrollar la resiliencia
ante la crisis climática las otras
galardonadas son indígenas que se
dedican al buceo para proteger los
corales el grupo sigue women of
melanesia es liderado por directoras
indígenas de las islas de papúa-nueva
guinea y salomón en oceanía las 40
personas que tiene esta organización le
enseñan a las mujeres locales a bucear y
combinan los conocimientos de la
población local con la biología para que
puedan monitorear la salud de los
arrecifes de coral así ayudan a
restaurar las áreas marinas protegidas
además de emisiones
hola mi nombre es you know trabajaba
como instructora de buceo a mar abierto
y fui feliz de unirme a see women of
milk a nation es bueno que haya
aprendido porque entre más aprendo de
esta fundación más me divierto lo bueno
es que hemos aprendido porque vivimos en
lugares rurales donde tenemos que cuidar
de la zona marina
es más renta
entonces nos beneficiamos y el turismo
también y la gente del pueblo puede
beneficiarse de esta área marítima
protegida gracias en que hay una ola de
turistas porque este es uno de los
destinos más importantes del mundo para
el turismo submarino la fundación
trabaja en el triángulo de coral que
cubre unos 57 millones de kilómetros
cuadrados entre la gran barrera de coral
y los archipiélagos insulares de
melanesia y el sudeste asiático la
principal amenaza de la zona es el
aumento de las poblaciones humanas y la
gran cantidad de desechos mientras que
los arrecifes de coral de todo el mundo
están asediados por el cambio climático
la sobrepesca y la contaminación las
mujeres que participan en el proyecto
están convencidas de que conservar los
corales ayuda a la seguridad alimentaria
de las futuras generaciones de todas sus
poblaciones las otras dos galardonadas
son de kirguistán y de uganda gladys
kaleme así q soca ganó el premio a la
ciencia y la innovación está veterinaria
de animales salvajes ha ayudado a
preservar a los primates de áfrica
oriental esto lo ha logrado trabajando
con las comunidades locales que viven
cerca de las áreas protegidas y
convenciendo a las personas de convivir
con estos animales en vez de atacarlos
además tanto en uganda como en república
democrática del congo ella promueve la
higiene especialmente en la interacción
entre las personas y la vida silvestre
esto lo hace desde hace 20 años con su
organización conservation of public
health o conservación a través de la
salud pública
en muchos lugares las presiones
económicas pueden causar fricciones
entre humanos y animales pero su trabajo
ha demostrado cómo se pueden superar los
conflictos cuando las comunidades
locales toman la iniciativa en la
protección de la naturaleza y la vida
silvestre que las rodea lo que genera
beneficios para todas las especies la
cuarta ganadora es mariah kolésnikova
esta mujer de kirguistán comenzó como
voluntaria en la ong green y escaló al
punto de ser su directora biskek la
capital kirguís am es una de las
ciudades con la peor contaminación de
aire del mundo wood green respondió
diseñando una aplicación llamada aqu
punto café que recolecta datos sobre la
calidad del aire en tiempo real esta
información sirvió para que los padres y
las escuelas evitarán que los niños se
expusieran a partículas finas de
contaminación la onu consideró que el
trabajo de kolésnikova refleja cómo las
personas pueden impulsar el cambio
utilizando la ciencia y hasta aquí
nuestro programa ustedes visiten más en
nuestra página web y en nuestro canal de
youtube hasta la próxima nos vemos
[Música]